the city of mariopol is almost totally
destroyed
in its ashes are at least a hundred
thousand people trapped and trying to
stay alive
but it's feared there could be far more
than that
the city is surrounded and the bombs
drop day and night
escaping from here on foot seems
unfathomable
but we've met one family who did
we watched as we went to the checkpoint
cars were shot there
there was an old man and woman in the
car they were shot next to each other
and for so many days they just were in
the car nobody picked their bodies up
we walked down the street and there was
an apocalypse around us
it was scary there it felt we were in a
horror movie as we walked away from the
city we saw broken tanks buses and
unexploded bombs
their composure is astounding
natalia and her son bogdan have made it
to the west of ukraine with the help of
strangers
but when they first escaped mariopol
four days ago they refused an offer by
russian forces to take them to russia
there is so much trauma and no trust
they showed us this video of their
bombed home
the shells started to hit they flew into
the yard broke down on balcony a man
went out on the balcony to smoke and the
balcony was hit by a shell he died
then more a bomb also flew into the
neighbor's house the house burned down
completely we decided to move from our
house to the next one and when we
reached it strong explosion started we
jumped into the entrance a bomb flew
into our car and exploded
they found themselves sheltering in a
basement for almost a month but with
enough food for just a few days
they had money in bank cards but there
was nothing to buy
there were problems with food because
everyone thought it would only be for a
few days and then we sat in a basement
and realized that we were there for 22
days
it was almost a month we had a spoonful
of porridge very little everyone lost
weight
their courage has carried them so far
but so many of their friends remain
trapped in mario pole and what that
means for them is a terrifying prospect
but for this family they no longer feel
safe in ukraine
poland is the next stop with no plan
beyond survival
sally lock with sky news levith in
western ukraine